sind wir allein in unserem gigantischen
universum mit milliarden von galaxien
und wiederum milliarden von sternen in
jeder dieser galaxien mit wie wir den
letzten jahren entdecken immer mehr
planeten die unserer erde ähnlich sind
könnte es bei diesen vielen chancen
nicht möglich sein das andere
intelligente lebensformen entstanden
sind
manche dieser lebensform könnten das
reisen im weltall erforscht haben so wie
wir es gerade tun und nur eine einzelne
zivilisation auf unserem heutigen
technologischen stand könnte die
milchstraße innerhalb von wenigen
millionen jahren komplett kolonisieren
was im vergleich zu den 13 milliarden
jahren die unsere galaxie bereits
existiert ein sehr kurzer zeitraum ist
wenn es also dort draußen eigentlich vor
außerirdischen leben wimmeln sollte
wie kann es da sein dass wir noch keinen
kontakt herstellen konnten
[Musik]
in der geschichte der menschheit hat der
kontakt zwischen zwei kulturell
unterschiedlichen zivilisationen fast
immer zum untergang einer dieser
zivilisation geführt könnte man also
annehmen dass der erste kontakt mit
außerirdischen leben auch tödlich enden
wird sollten wir vielleicht lieber unter
uns bleiben
auf der anderen seite wurde fast immer
die zivilisation zerstört die besuchte
wurde
während die besucher her überlebten
sollten wir also lieber möglichst
schnell versuchen fremdes leben zu
finden bevor es uns findet aber gehen
wir erst mal einen schritt zurück wieso
hat es dennoch keinen kontakt mit
außerirdischen gegeben wie ich vorhin
gesagt habe gibt es millionen wenn nicht
milliarden erdähnliche planeten viele
davon mit sternen die älter sind als
unsere sonne
wo sind all die aliens die durchs
weltall fliegen sollten
das ist das fermi paradoxon benannt nach
dem italienischen physiker enrico fermi
und es gibt drei mögliche antworten die
diese frage beantworten können
erstens wir sind wirklich allein
vielleicht sind wir als vielseitiges
leben im universum oder zumindest in
unserer galaxie eine seltenheit
vielleicht waren die konditionen hier
auf der erde so astronomisch
unwahrscheinlich das leben wie wir es
kennen bisher wirklich nur einmal
entstanden ist
dazu sollte man erwähnen dass wir selbst
in einem labor noch nie künstliche
lebensformen erschaffen konnten die
gleichzeitig evolutionär anpassungsfähig
komplex und entscheidungsfähig sind so
wie wir selber wenn es also schon
beinahe unmöglich ist leben zu
erschaffen wenn alle faktoren
kontrolliert werden können
wie viele jahre dauert es dann bis dies
per zufall passiert zweitens
außerirdisches leben existiert verlässt
aber nicht seinen heimatplaneten
vielleicht ist nur die entstehung von
intelligent zum leben extrem
unwahrscheinlich und überall im
universum gibt es planeten mit millionen
verschiedener tierarten so wie hier auf
der erde
vielleicht gibt es dort sogar
intelligentes leben das aber noch nicht
so fortgeschritten ist wie wir oder
vielleicht gibt es einfach keinen anreiz
die gesamte galaxie zu kolonisieren
vielleicht ist abenteuerlust ein sehr
menschliches gefühl und andere
intelligente lebensformen ziehen es vor
auf ihrem eigenen planeten zu bleiben
vielleicht schaffen sie sich sogar ihre
eigene traumwelt per virtual reality
was spricht schon gegen ein perfektes
leben wie im traum drittens auslöschung
das ist die unangenehmste erklärung denn
sie besagt dass jede technologisch
fortschrittliche zivilisation zerstört
wird bevor sie ins weltall aufbrechen
kann entweder durch eigene fehler wie
bei uns zum beispiel durch atom kriege
globale erderwärmung oder das erschaffen
einer künstlichen intelligenz oder durch
die zerstörung von außen
gammastrahlenausbrüche können innerhalb
von wenigen sekunden unmengen tödliche
strahlung aussenden wenn das oft genug
passiert könnte das dafür sorgen dass
keine lebensform in der nähe dieser
strahlen lange genug am leben bleibt um
sich weit genug von diesen strahlen zu
entfernen
und vielleicht gibt es ja auch eine
extrem fortschrittliche zivilisation da
draußen nur sorgt sie dafür dass sie
auch die einzige bleibt und tötet jede
lebensform die beginnt sich von ihrem
heimatplaneten zu entfernen
diese letzte möglichkeit ist ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich aber es ist bestimmt
die variante die wir mit abstand am
häufigsten im kinofilm sehen
aliens die auf die erde kommen und uns
angreifen
dabei ist es viel viel wahrscheinlicher
dass der erste kontakt mit
außerirdischen leben wenn er jemals
stattfindet über das radio kommt anstatt
uns persönlich zu besuchen und dabei
wahrscheinlich jahrzehnte ihrer zeit und
viel energie zu verbrauchen
da gibt es viel mehr sinn vorher
nachrichten zu verschicken und so
kontakt aufzunehmen
dafür benutzen sie womöglich
elektromagnetische wellen im
radiobereich
da diese am besten dafür geeignet sind
extrem lange distanzen zu überbrücken
unter anderem deshalb hören
wissenschaftler ständig ins weltall
hinein zu horchen nach möglichen
nachrichten von fremden lebewesen die
absichtlich oder unabsichtlich ins
weltall hinaus geschickt wurden
unabsichtlich machen wir das übrigens
schon seit 80 jahren mit radio und
fernseh übertragungen
aber was würden wir eigentlich tun wenn
wir wirklich einmal eine nachricht von
extraterrestrischen lebewesen erhalten
würden
der erste schritt eine nachricht von
fremden lebewesen zu entschlüsseln ist
herauszufinden was die nachricht
eigentlich ist sind es binäre signale
ist es natürliche sprache oder
vielleicht etwas ganz anderes wenn es
eine sprache ist dann könnten wir das
unter gewissen umständen herausfinden
jede sprache die wir bisher untersucht
haben folgt einer simplen regel dass das
wort das in der sprache am meisten
verwendet wird doppelt so häufig
vorkommt wie das am zweitmeisten
verwendete das dritte wort wird zu einem
drittel so oft verwendet wie das erste
und das führte zu einem viertel so oft
und so weiter die wort häufigkeit folgt
einer logarithmischen kurve und das
trifft sogar auf sprachen zu die nicht
miteinander verwandt sind
man nimmt diese regel auch das töpfchen
gesetzt und das interessante daran ist
dass dieses gesetz für sehr sehr viele
dinge gilt nicht nur für wort häufigkeit
entsprachen die logarithmische
verteilung findet sich auch in der
häufigkeit der buchstaben selber in der
größe von großstädten oder unternehmen
sogar in der häufigkeit von erdbeben
oder waldbränden und wissenschaftler
konnten noch nicht mit sicherheit
herausfinden warum so viele dinge dem
typischen gesetz folgen
daher also scheinbar größere
naturgesetze dahinter stehen kann man
davon ausgehen dass eine sprache von
extraterrestrischen lebewesen auch
diesem gesetz folgt natürlich nur wenn
sie eine verbale oder schriftliche
sprache benutzen die in erkennbare worte
also einzelteile unterteilt werden kann
aber selbst wenn wir die nachricht als
sprache identifizieren können haben wir
wahrscheinlich keine möglichkeit die
sprache zu übersetzen geschweige denn
die bedeutung der nachricht zu verstehen
wenn linguisten alte sprachen entziffern
benutzen sie dabei so weit möglich
verwandte sprachen als referenz und
vergleichs punkt für die sprache der
aliens gibt es aber keine referenz
vielleicht sollten wir uns jetzt schon
gedanken machen wie wir mit
außerirdischen leben kommunizieren
könnten sobald ein erster kontakt
hergestellt ist wie sollte unsere erste
nachricht aussehen
eine erste nachricht muss möglichst
allgemein gehalten werden sonst könnten
die außerirdischen die nachricht
eventuell nicht entziffern
sie darf also keine anthropologische
sprache mit grammatik oder vokabeln
verwenden die nachricht muss aber
trotzdem eine oder mehrere ideen
kommunizieren die hoffentlich dabei
helfen weitere informationen
auszutauschen
die berühmteste erste nachricht an
außerirdische ist wohl die pioneer
plakette diese kleine vergoldete
plakette wurde außen an den
interstellaren raum sollten pioneer 10
und 11 befestigt und flug mit diesen
1972 ins all
für den unwahrscheinlichen fall dass
aliens die raumsonde finden sollten sind
mehrere nachrichten auf der plakette
angebracht
ganz oben links befindet sich eine
darstellung von zwei wasserstoffatomen
dem häufigsten element im universum
dieses wird genutzt um einheiten zu
definieren die im binärsystem überall
auf der plakette verwendet werden zum
beispiel um die position unserer sonne
in relation zu 14 pulsaren und dem
zentrum der galaxie zu definieren
daneben sind zwei darstellungen von uns
mann und frau mit einer maßangaben meter
68 in binär und das ganze in relation zu
der pioneer raumsonde selber ganz unten
sind unsere zu dieser zeit noch neun
planeten dargestellt sowie der weg den
die sonne hinter sich gebracht hat trotz
langer vorbereitung wurde die plakette
viel kritisiert angefangen von der
tatsache dass die erhobene hand
fälschlicherweise als aggressive
nachricht verstanden werden könnte über
die tatsache dass selbst hier auf der
erde viele wissenschaftler nicht alle
hinweise entschlüsseln konnten bis hin
zum teil der genutzt wurde um eine
richtung zu erklären
das symbol stammt vermutlich entweder
vom pfeil und bogen oder von der art und
weise wie wir mit unserem finger auf
etwas zeigen
beides werden außerirdische
wahrscheinlich nicht haben und verstehen
deswegen wahrscheinlich nicht welche
bedeutung das symbol trägt außerdem
wissen wir natürlich wie man die
plakette richtig hält aber woher soll
ein alien wissen dass menschen nicht so
auf ihrem kopf stehen oder ständig auf
der seite liegen
und auch dass er überhaupt eine plakette
benutzt haben zeigt wer wir sind
wir haben keine ahnung wie fremde
lebewesen informationen aufnehmen
wir sind eine visuelle spezies weil wir
sehr gute augen haben
für uns ist es intuitiv informationen
visuell
ermitteln aber was ist wenn die
außerirdischen nicht oder nur schlecht
sehen können so wie viele lebensarten
auf unserer erde vielleicht
kommunizieren die außerirdischen über
geräusche oder ihren tastsinn oder sogar
über dinge wie groß oder elektrizität
und selbst wenn sie sehen können oder
kameras entwickelt haben die visuelle
eindrücke in ihren primären sinn
übertragen
dann sind sie vielleicht einfach nicht
mit der abstrakten art und weise
vertraut wie wir uns gezeichnet haben
für aliens sind das vielleicht nur wirre
kritzeleien menschen die eine lange zeit
ihres lebens blind waren sehen in diesen
sogenannten neckar würfel keinen
dreidimensionalen würfel sondern nur
striche ihm fehlt das verständnis für
diese art der visuellen darstellung
wenn also jede form der kommunikation
falsch oder gar nicht verstanden werden
könnte weil wir so grundlegend
verschieden sind wie kann man dann mit
außerirdischen leben vernünftig sprechen
soweit wir wissen sind mathematik und
logik überall im universum gleich egal
wo man sich befindet und wie man fragt
eins plus eins ergibt 2 natürlich sind
die worte oder die symbole dafür anders
aber man kann das ganze auch visuell
oder akustisch oder am radio signal
darstellen
links ist eine konstruierte sprache die
eigens für die kommunikation mit
außerirdischen leben erfunden wurde
sie basiert ausschließlich auf logik und
kommuniziert wenn man so will durch
mathematik
trotzdem kann man sich fragen ob man mit
hilfe dieser sprache wirklich effizient
kommunizieren kann
wie würde man tiefgründige konzepte wie
freiheit würde oder menschlichkeit durch
zahlen und rechenoperationen ausdrücken
wenn ein löwe sprechen könnte würden wir
ihn nicht verstehen
das schrieb der österreichische
philosoph ludwig wittgenstein
dahinter steckt die idee dass lebewesen
von zwei grundsätzlich verschiedene
kulturen sich nicht verstehen würden
selbst wenn sie dieselbe sprache
sprechen würden
das wirklich schwierige beim
kommunizieren mit außerirdischen leben
wird nicht das übersetzen sein sondern
die bedeutung der worte nachvollziehen
zu können
ein fremdes lebewesen das sich ganz
anders entwickelt hat als wir in einer
fremden kultur die unserer vielleicht in
kaum einer form endet hat eine andere
art und weise zu denken zumindest in
letzer hinsicht könnte die fremde
sprache für uns allerdings hilfreich
sein
die zafira hypothese besagt dass eine
sprache die art und weise formt und
beeinflusst wie jemand denkt du hast
eine andere persönlichkeit wenn englisch
deine muttersprache ist im vergleich zu
deutsch oder chinesisch vielleicht
können wir durch das erlernen einer
wirklich treppen sprache eine neue art
zu denken erlernen eine neue sichtweise
auf das universum in dem wir leben und
vielleicht schauen wir eines tages auf
die heutige zeit zurück als wir gerade
angefangen haben das weltall zu
erforschen und schmunzeln bei dem
gedanken dass wir jemals so naiv sein
konnten zu glauben dass wir in einem so
großen universum allein sein könnten
[Musik]
ein riesiges dankeschön geht an meine
page supporter niklas lehnert und alex
die mich bei diesem video unterstützt
haben vielen dank dafür
wenn jetzt noch nicht mitbekommen habt
ich habe jetzt eine petri an seite auf
der ihr mir helfen könnt noch mehr und
vor allem aufwendigere videos wie zb
dieses hier zu produzieren
wir stehen auch kurz davor einen
sogenannten meilenstein zu erreichen bei
dem stand ein besonderes video
produzieren werde und wie bei anderen
kathrin seiten auch gibt es verschiedene
belohnungen dafür dass ihr mich
unterstützt
für mehr infos schaut euch einfach
meiner um der link ist wie alles andere
auch unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bis zum nächsten mal
patrick